let's think about what it means to take
8/3 and divide it by one-third so let me
draw a number line here so there is my
number line this is 0 this is 1 and this
is 2 maybe this is 3 right over here and
let me plot 8/3 so to do that I just
need to break up my each each hole into
thirds so let's see it's one-third
two-thirds three-thirds 4/3 5/3
6 thirds 7/3 8/3 so right over here and
then of course 9/3 would get us to 3 so
this right over here is 8/3 8/3 now one
way to think about 8/3 divided by 3 is
what if we take this length and we say
how many jumps would it take to get
there if we're doing it in jumps of 1/3
or essentially we're breaking this up if
we were to break up 8/3 into sections of
1/3 how many sections would I have or
how many jumps what I have well let's
think about that if we're trying to take
jumps of 1/3 we're gonna have to go 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8
jumps so we could view this as we could
you let me do this in a different color
in this orange so we took these 8 jumps
right over here so we could view 8/3
divided by 1/3 as being equal to 8 now
why is this actually make sense well
when you're dividing things in 2/3 for
every hole you're now going to have 3
jumps so whatever value you're trying to
get to you're going to have that number
times 3 jumps so another way of thinking
about it is that 8/3 8/3 divided by
divided by 1/3 is the same thing as 8/3
8/3 times 3 now we could either write it
like this we could write x 3 like that
or if we want to write 3 as a fraction
we know that 3 is the same thing
three over one and when we already know
how to multiply fractions a multiply the
numerators eight times three so you have
eight let me do that that same color you
have eight times three in the numerator
now eight times three and then you have
three times 1 in the denominator
three times three times one in the
denominator which would give you 24
thirds which is the same thing as 24
divided by three which once again is
equal is equal to is equal to is equal
to eight now let's see if this still
makes sense instead of dividing by
one-third if we were divided by
two-thirds so let's think about what 8/3
divided by two-thirds is divided by
two-thirds
well once again this is like asking the
question if we wanted to break up this
section from zero to 8/3 into sections
of 2/3 or jumps of two-thirds how many
sections or how many jumps would I have
to make well let's think about it one
jump just in a different color we could
make one jump that's the same color as
my 8/3 we could do one jump my computer
is doing something strange we could do
one jump two jumps three jumps and four
jumps so we see 8/3 divided by 2/3 is
equal is equal to four now does this
make sense in this world right over here
well if we take 8/3 and we do the same
thing saying hey look dividing by a
fraction is the same thing as
multiplying by a reciprocal
well let's multiply by three halves
let's multiply by the reciprocal of 2/3
so we swap the numerator and the
denominator so we multiply it times
three halves and then what do we get in
the numerator once again we get eight
times three which is 24 and in the
denominator we get 3 times 2 which is 6
so now we get 24 divided by 6
is equal to four now does it make sense
that we got half the answer if you think
about the difference between what we did
here and what we did here these are
almost the same except here we really
just didn't divide or you could say you
divided by one while here you / - well
does that make sense well sure because
here you jumped twice as far you jumped
twice as far so you had to take half the
number of steps and so in the first
example you saw why it makes sense to
multiply by 3 when you divide by a
fraction for every hole you're making 3
jumps so that's why when you divide by
this fraction you multiply or when you
divide whatever's in the denominator you
multiply by it and now when the
numerator is greater than 1 every jump
you're going twice as far as you did in
this first one right over here and so
you would have to do half as many jumps
hopefully that makes sense it's easy to
think about just mechanically how to
divide fractions dividing 8/3 divided by
1/3 is the same thing as 8/3 times 3
over 1 or 8/3 divided by 2/3 is the same
thing as 8/3 times 3 over 2 but
hopefully this this video gives you a
little bit more of an intuition of why
this is the case